from timcast.com
Tucker Carlson says America is speeding
toward assassination of Donald Trump
that's a scary Prospect he said they
process protested him they called him
names he won anyway they impeached him
twice on ridiculous pretenses they
fabricated a lot about what happened on
January 6 in order to impeach him again
it didn't work he came back then they
indicted him it didn't work he became
more popular then they indebted him
three more times and every single time
his popularity rose so if you begin with
criticism then you go to a protest and
you go to impeachment and you go to
indictment none of them work what's next
I mean you know graph it out man we're
speeding toward assassination obviously
and no one will say that but I don't
know how you can't reach that conclusion
you know what I mean like they have
decided permanent Washington both
parties have decided that there's
something about Trump that's so
threatening to them they just can't have
them
he later commented I don't know where
it's going but there's a collusion
that's clearly imminent I've never been
this worried about anything as I am
about where this is going
if people don't get serious about their
comfort zones I think they're going to
demonize him indict him indict him and
died him indict him and I think they'll
blow his airplane up Jones says Alex
Jones I really at a gut level believe
they're going to kill Trump
there was a story in I think it was 2015
a guy tried grabbing a gun from a cop at
a trump rally there's already been
threats made against Donald Trump and I
guess we can only hope and pray it
doesn't come to that but Tucker makes a
really interesting point
now I will counter he's not gotten Pop
more popular every time they've indicted
him because I I I tracked the
favorability and popular to trump it is
stable
stable is
is potentially as bad or worse
stable means that there are people who
don't care what the government does or
says they will never abandon Trump
that's it it also says there are people
that no matter what will never support
Trump right if Trump got more or less
popular because the indictments that
would mean something becoming less
popular means there are people who
supported him but now are backing away
if he becomes more popular it means that
people who didn't support him are
starting to support him no it hasn't
changed because it's locked in right now
the left and the right whatever you want
to call it the political factions are
stable and that means all the things
they're doing are just radicalizing
people and and making the Flames bigger
and more dangerous
which I kind of assume is what they want
right I don't know
I mean it's
man there's a lot of scenarios in my
mind but if Tucker is correct I don't
see how this country survives another
year two years year and a half I don't I
don't think Tucker is correct I forget
who we had on the show but he said you
can't in 2023 you can't do what you did
in the 60s right you can't give somebody
the Kennedy treatment I think they've
already done it to Trump and we've seen
it's the indictments it's the mainstream
media with all the pieces throughout his
presidency it's all of that that they've
already taken them down or at least
attempted to I don't think so I don't
think Trump trump is predicted to win
right now if you if so CNN reported this
not my opinion calm down crackpots CNN
said right now based on all the data
they got it's looking really good for
Trump now I take into consideration that
the student loan debt about to kick back
on in the next couple of weeks the think
about this
so I was talking to my girlfriend about
this earlier I said you know uh we I was
passively talking about it and then she
was like wait they're they're everyone's
got to pay back their student loans
again starting in a couple weeks and I'm
like yeah something like that and then
she was like they're not going to have
the money and I'm like right exactly and
then I said in the question then becomes
how do they pay for their student loans
if right now we got all these videos of
young people saying I can't afford my
bills
how are they going to pay back their
student loans if student loan repayment
restarts they're not
and then I'm like so so it's kind of
like 2008 they gave out loans to people
who didn't have credit couldn't afford
it and then my girlfriend was like well
they got their parents to co-sign she's
like a lot of these people got their
parents to co-sign and I was like
interesting then when these 27 28 year
olds don't pay back their loans and then
the lenders say
your you know your your mom or dad is a
co-signer and goes to them and says you
got to pay and they go we can't afford
to pay they go then we take your house
and we're seeing tick tocks of people
that age crying saying I did what I was
supposed to do I got the degree I work
hard I don't party I did everything I
was supposed to do and I can't afford
food and I guarantee if it becomes
between student loans and putting food
on your table you're not gonna pay the
student loans so you're gonna let them
default but then what are you gonna do
when you're like sorry Mom and Dad I'm
gonna you're gonna lose your house
you're gonna have to pay the consequence
of my actions I mean that is the result
of the student loan thing but I think
it's going to make a very divided and
bitter Society a bailout yeah the only
the only circumstance that seems to make
sense would be a government bailout of
the student loan system and that is
going to be a disaster because that's
another trillion plus instantly pumped
into the economy by way of forgiveness
which will cause massive inflation or is
already contributed to it but oh boy if
you thought Richmond North or Richmond
was bad wait till you go to the likes of
Oliver Anthony and say oh here's the
best part the highest income earners in
the country who have nothing but disdain
for you and told you told you to go
learn to code just got a 50 000 freebie
from the government yeah and if that
happened that would mean put pump
another trillion in would mean that your
dollar is worth like 96 cents right
after that happens all those people that
already paid their loans back that have
their money devalued are gonna go I mean
maybe not all of them but it's not a lot
of them get angry at people that are
taking tits off the taking the
government's tip to go back to the the
initial story like Tucker is saying
where does it go next
people need to consider that none of
this stuff is happening in a vacuum and
when it came to the lockdowns uh and the
George Floyd riots I actually think the
lockdowns were the cause of the riots
not George Floyd we had seen protests
before I do not believe the George Floyd
video is the reason why we had such
massive and widespread writing I think
the writing was likely
people were fed up they were locked in
their homes they were angry they had no
income their purpose was stripped they
were becoming unhinged and depressed and
then they were given some you know a
spark for the Tinder a lot of people
will probably say it was George Floyd
whatever
the media definitely said it was George
Floyd but I think we talked about it at
the time that this pent-up rage from
being locked up so you take a look at
what's going on with Donald Trump as
president
you take a look what's happening now
with student loan repayment about to
kick in the economy may fall off a cliff
in the next couple of months we got the
guy from Shark Tank saying it you got
Michael burry of big short Fame who
shorted the housing market making a 1.6
billion dollar bet against the S P 500
and NASDAQ I think both it might just be
s p
and we don't know if he's if he's uh uh
actually cashed out yet or where he's at
but he made a very very big bet against
the US economy and the student loan
repayment seems to make the most sense
people who don't have jobs who can't
afford to pay their bills being told the
bill comes due they're not going to pay
it if you go up to a 27 year old and say
you can pay your rent you can buy your
gas or you can buy food or you can pay
your student loans they're gonna say
okay well if I don't have food I die if
I don't have gas I can't go to work and
can't make money and if I don't pay a
runtime homeless sorry student loans
ain't getting paid for anybody that has
student loans that isn't able to afford
them right now you can do two things you
can put them on a forbearance or you can
put them on a deferment depending on
your income level so look into that that
can you can set them off for years and
not have to pay them but isn't most of
the student loan debt basically owe to
the government yes
over 90 I think it's like 90 at minimum
94 the majority of it is owned by the
government so the government gave you
bad loans and then is saying you have to
pay them actually we might just bail
ourselves out we don't know what we're
gonna do I mean it's a terrible system
and we're still issuing student loans
sorry I don't want to cut you off no no
it's a point of irritation with me
because it just seems like a terrible
business model you get the US
government's like no it's fine keep
getting student loans go to college
that's the answer even though we have
evidence it's so clear the system is
broken and potentially could destroy
generations of a family that have worked
really hard to to create Financial
stability yeah I completely agree and
and speaking from the perspective of a
father my son is 17 he'll be 18 October
um and I've I've written articles about
this and talked about it on TV you know
Raising a Son
um and you know someone who's looking
like me the older he gets and I'm
thinking about
his prosperity
the only thing I've ever been worried
about with my son is what is he going to
do as far as College that's the only
thing I wasn't worried about puberty I
wasn't worried about any of that stuff
worrying about him you know being
rebellious never worried about that the
only thing I've ever been worried about
probably since the age of 12 is like oh
my God my son's about to be a teenager
and he's going to start thinking about
what he's going to do after school and I
think about how unfair of a message it
is to to spread to kids that the only
way for you to find success is a sign on
the dotted line you have no credit
history right you have no income you
have no job prospects but you have to
sign in the dotted line and have hope
that whatever your intending to pursue
is going to work out and obviously
that's not what happens and every year
some kid is competing against you and so
on and so forth and they're unprepared
and then you send them out into the
world so they work at Starbucks making
minimum wage
and tell them they have to pay back
eighty thousand dollars meanwhile their
parents told them well that's what we
did yes but you're not in their
situation you're not dealing with a
gouging student loan Market you're not
dealing with universities who can charge
whatever they want because the federal
government will pay it anyways right
they're not dealing with these things
and parents
as a parent I'm saying other parents
have given their children bad
information and they're not being aware
of what is actually going on they're
just telling them to follow my footsteps
or they're following their footsteps
into Financial hell basically
yeah it's like the area that they walked
through is now flooded and they tell
their kid to walk back through it that's
not a good tactic it's like when parents
say well why don't you just go work at
McDonald's that's how I I've paid my way
through college yeah you can't do that
these days so how did you inspire your
son what's his next move what if what
advice did you give him I told him I
told him the truth I told him that
college is incredibly expensive and you
need to weigh all options there was a
period of time that he wanted to do
um uh Artistry and he wanted to go over
to Japan I I've told him go to other
countries Japan's good yeah now he's
changed that idea and he's still
thinking about it but I'm not one of
those parents like you have to do
something as soon as you turn 18. he
wants to go bounce around Europe next
year but he's working he's been working
this entire time we've we started doing
homeschooling but I'm having him think
for himself rather than force a
narrative onto him that the only way to
find success in this world is through
college and for me as someone who uh
worked in I.T I did the same job as
everybody else who got their computer
science degree I I went to a 11-month
program you know for a tech school
instead of four years of bachelor's and
crazy amounts of tuition yeah I pay my
student loans are are paid off so you
know there are alternatives and I think
parents just have to be aware that what
you went through is not what these kids
are going through they're set up for
failure going that route they're set up
for a lifetime of a financial hurt and
radicalization and radicalization one
other thing I just want to add
we're talking about the economy dipping
interest rates for housing you know my
wife and I are looking to buy a house
next year we're looking at the interest
rate what's the situation that we're
going to be facing so now the kids have
I don't know how much money in debt the
interest rates are going up so even if
some kid able to find a decent job they
can't afford to to purchase a home
rent's gone up one of the reasons we're
looking to buy a house is because we
renewed our lease 300 increase yep now
thankfully we have we make decent income
together but we're a married couple what
about these kids right so I just I
foresee I foresee the Europe is uh like
a European style setup that's happening
in America because all the European
adults that I know most of them live
with other people live with other adults
we all have roommates that's where we're
gone thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time